Cái mùa 2 thống 1 bụng trường trên sẵn bị ổng viết theo xí trở biết,
của đợi Mỹ đã tiến hàng thêm 1 cột tập kích nhằm vào một tạo bị cáo bước vận trình
mà tìa tài của biển kè bê khiến mang ở trên mạng.
Ông theo xí trở biết, trên dịch được trên khai theo chì đạo của tổng thống Mỹ đường
ở trông nhằm vào một tạo gió tổ trức tổ và mặt tủy điều hàng và bị Washington,
Liet vào vàng sách cùng bố. Chào hà xí trở,
tình bảo Mỹ sẽ định có tổ này liên qua đến hoạt động vận bản mặt tủy và dí chuyển trên
hàng hải thường xuyên cho khu vực. Đây là vụ tấn công thống Mỹ Lâm kể từ đầu tháng chiến trong
kinh dịch truy quát tất cả tạo bị Mỹ cáo bước vận trẻ mặt tủy ở vùng gày bê và kìa đông
thay bị giống khiến ít nhất sống mới tư người thêm mạng.
Ông Washington cho rằng nhóm tội phạm hoạt động tại đây có liên hệ ở bởi mạng lời buồn lộ của tế và
nè rõ anh đến của Mỹ, sau trường công bố văn trường của thế. Vụ tấn công dễ ra trong bối cạnh,
nhiều cuốc gia và tổ chức của tế đã liên anh hành động này. Lên hệ của ngày 3 mốt tháng
mười trước đó kêu của Mỹ trấm rất công hả động của Nth cạnh báo việc sự dụng
bụt lực về thường vòng dân sự là bị phạm là pháp của tế. Ngà cùng cho rằng Mỹ đang
sự dụng bụt lực quả mất anh hưởng tới anh đến khu vực kỷ bê.